hey guys there was another fan made
subscriber milestone video and
apparently this one has over a thousand
fans reacting to me reacting to
something or other as with the six
million subscriber video I'm going to be
doing the same thing I'm gonna be
filming my reaction to their reaction to
my reaction and make it all come full
circle so this video that you're
watching now may be cut down but the
original video is almost 30 minutes long
so if you want to see the full uncut
version check the link in the
description below thanks everybody here
we go
emotions abound because I know how
[Music]
playthrough it's this human aspect that
creates friendship empathy shared
emotions and experiences trust enjoyment
it's this human aspect that provides the
foundation for community because what
you feel is what we do to train you
ridge new heights with us and when you
hit rock bottom you surely aren't alone
when you show emotion we see it all our
ability is a part of sharing and just as
we've gained from your sharing we'd like
to share her emotion with you - this is
our reaction do you react hasn't even
started yet what am i doing just about
to watch the video with you oh and I'm
ready to be inundated with emotions coos
oh here we are just about the right time
this is so bad a song because I started
it so better
so silly
there wasn't me watching them but
watched them oh man
[Music]
I just want to give you the heart
baby Jesus
[Music]
shut up me let the thing play soundcheck
and its cover
oh why is everybody crying come that's
okay I'm just being stupid that's right
you're a mess shut up Flicka be that's
okay geez everybody let me bear this one
it's okay I thought I was gonna be able
to handle it now in the future I'm not
sad I'm not sad I'm sad no it's okay
it's okay didn't want it to be a sad
video like
the entire time I was there I couldn't
help to think there was only one person
in the world that who would have wanted
to see me there and I couldn't stop
thinking about how how proud my dad
would have been he was like the biggest
Patriot if anyone could have ever been
he was a 24-year military man and you
know he never really agreed with what
I'm crying up for the both of us teeth
before that became a joke that really
meant something to me I'm just seeing
all these people here is
[Music]
oh it's okay everyone it's so heavy oh
man I don't mean to make people sad
bye-bye
man go away please he's you're making
everyone emotional me probably doing it
again now people
[Music]
videos have got me through
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much thank you so much thank you so much
for being such a huge inspiration for
thank you for being my friend thank you
so much thank you so much for being the
supportive guy that you are and being
the one that always puts smiles on
people's faces
[Music]
thank you being the sunshine on some of
our darkest days being the reason that I
can get through my day thank you so much
thank you so much for being here
[Music]
Oh bye okay
I would be waiving for a while are they
well goodbye everybody
Oh such a blubbering mess
[Music]
it's hard to look at everyone oh I'm
start reading death my face
[Music]
my wavy garbs are getting tired
get away by our booth play out there ARB
I want to get every I don't want to miss
anyone oh this
[Music]
I saw that mannequin oh I know this more
people I've been here day in day out
there is out loud what I never
knew I you would be here too
say took my short steps breathe my deep
breaths as it cuz of you talk over cuz
you would see me through did I make it
clear that I love you from the other
side of the screen
did I try and laugh to convince you of
what I really mean you are here I'm so
beautiful God I did that how did things
turn out this way I'm living my dream
each day giving what I can and learning
Who I am
and now around me these sounds are
homeland I see and everywhere I go I
hope that my heart shows did I say in
love that I love you from the other side
of the screen and do I seem sincere when
I thank you cuz I mean just what I mean
but now I see you all are here
you are
yeah
I see you all are here with me
[Music]
Oh bad all right probably more I've been
here day in day out said I love you out
loud what I never knew is that you would
be you too is that it is it the end have
I done it before
oh no here we go
I do I said I was in
[Music]
Oh Oh did she make that song oh that's
so crazy I'll put a link for that in the
description okay whoa was this high wait
Oh
grandpa
[Music]
I can't think about 800
oh man oh that's so cool it's so cool
all right I love rain I'll put in some
rain at this I'll blend it together with
more rain oh oh there was 30 minutes
already geez ah god I don't even know
how to cut that into anything
oh man oh there were so many people it's
just like a tiny fraction okay
alright so what I'm trying to say is
what I've been trying to say through the
whole video is just that I'm and I am
tired
did it oh god I cannot get through
single citizens
[Music]
everything is alright why do
my words
always there
[Music]
all right
Oh
[Music]
uh-uh above all else off anything that
I'm trying to say here I just want to
say thank you guys so much for believing
in me I do but more importantly like
infinitely more importantly thank you
guys so much for believing in each other
because I know this community is gonna
keep growing and I know that we're gonna
hit more milestones down the road and
that's cause for celebration but the
real thing that we always need to
remember is that we are here for each
other and you have to be because some
people out there you know some people in
these videos they don't have anyone else
and they turn to me and they turn to
everyone else who reaches out in this
community I'm honored that you've taken
that to heart and then you you strive to
do better in the world and then you want
to drive good back into the world in
using this community as a platform to
promote that goodwill is the best thing
that I could hope for because I want you
guys to know that I'm a person I want
you guys to know that I'm an individual
you know you can call me markiplier mark
or whatever I'm the same person I'm
always going to be the same person I'm
always going to be me and I'm always
going to be honest with you and I really
really hope that you guys believe me
when I say that I care about what you do
and who you are because I can't know you
on an individual level and I'm speaking
to you as if the whole I can't know
every eight million people on an
individual level and that's what tears
me up inside
because I want to because I know there's
people that need me to talk to them I
can't do that I know this people need me
and I want to be there for them so badly
I do I want to bear the burden for them
I would bear but I can't and that's what
sucks posts about it but here's buddy's
cupboard but that's where you guys
covered that's where you could help me
you could help me by reaching out to
those that need help the most because I
can do a lot I can do a lot and that's
why I need to stand you know all the
soapbox telling you guys to be good
that's why I need to be there this while
I'm so proud that you guys have oh babe
and I just had to watch this on Father's
Day I didn't even know it was Father's
Day until people started telling me on
Twitter and oh man if you didn't know my
dad is the greatest guy I've ever met in
my life in um I'm only me and I know
that I only have the values that I have
because he instilled them in me and I'd
like to think that I'm passing on those
values to you guys in some small way or
another and I don't mean to keep harping
on about sad stuff I don't want to I
don't want this to be happy and I want
this to be you know good for everybody
to enjoy so I'm probably just gonna wrap
this up because I've been recording for
a long time though so at the end of it
all thank you guys so much for being
here for me and thank you guys so much
for being there for each other
thank you markiplier sings badly I think
his name's James Fay cubes arcade with
the chili I really hope I get it wrong
that's such a cool thank you M's for
singing and composing that song and all
the other things that you've done and
thank you to everyone for every piece of
fan art every well wish every good
intention just thank you all so much for
everything and you've done it's a debt
that I could never ever repay but I'm
more than happy to keep trying so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye